alle mein name ist bekommen wir heute
einen neuen dienst leistet kann ich
gestern ein video hochgeladen was die
flucht die fischer entschieden als ampel
habe ich mich genommen die ich auch
einen abgeschnittenen finger dort
reagiert habe aber erstmal darum in dem
video ging haben das video handelt davon
dass alle greifen da kann ich hab mich
viele aufgaben gestellt ich muss diese
aufgaben beantworten welcher gemacht
habe kann diese aufgabe wenn das falsch
gemacht habe dann muss ich auch die
breite gehen und musste mir halt
irgendwie klafften link anschauen wie
sache dabei war und das hab ich sogar in
dem video gedacht ich hoffe die videos
nicht ab 18
doch das video jetzt wieder frei gegeben
wurde
ich weiß nicht warum weil ich eigentlich
wirklich alles wenn wir haben also der
wahre frau die versuchen dann würde dir
die fresse bekommen da hab ich aus
meinem einig darüber dass man wirklich
nicht gesehen hat und die andere klasse
sache bei einfach mit dem finger oder
mittelabschnitt waren voller blut aber
auch mai lief auf das blut gemacht damit
man wirklich nicht wählen konnte es
allerdings gewesen dass youtube die
dachluke der hat bestimmt gegen die
altersbeschränkung richtlinien verstoßen
weil youtube bedeutet mal einige
kommentare unter dem video vorschreiben
alter bin ein 1 1 1 1
ich glaube du müsstest erstmal lernen
wie man alte henke schreibe aber ich
find's schön das ist auch löwen
verschlingt von big hit like warum
mitbewerbers mit geräte es bei mir steht
dieses video hat eine alltags
beschreibung dazu beschreibung baualter
beschreibung ein love you but mussten
video ohne altersbeschränkung machen
will kann ich deiner fabelhaften videos
nicht sehen
ich habe die altersbeschränkung nicht
eines der highlights bedrängnis wurde
die klage ok dieses video wird nicht
selber sagen im schnitt bei kindern ab
18 oder youtube macht also wie machen
findet wenige dieser effekt kann ebay ok
bin ich mich um verkommt reicht
allerdings alles in mir habe und mich
komplett an die richtige fahrkarte nach
berlin
aber ich hatte schon auch für meine
probleme mit youtube
altersbeschränkungen in der tat in der
beschreibung steht altersbeschränkung
mir kommt mit einem laptop die meldungen
wurden drei quellen decken wenn ihr auch
okay
rückschläge da ihr handy wird ihr würde
schon gesperrt werden
nein youtube von google unter dem
anwender eine beschreibung steht eine
beschränkung dann habt ihr kein leeres
wenn ihr darauf wieder ehrlich
draufklicken aber ich verstehe die man
auf eine aussage kommen leute finden
gerade im schnitt von fahrgästen und
einen kommentar nach vorzustellen und
war für das video beschrieben als ob das
eine altersbeschränkung hatten einig die
abonnieren
aber verstehe das nicht meine absicht
war es am tag kommentare von euch nur
unter dem video gepostet wurden haben
einfach ihr in dem video nur zu sagen ja
auch mein video altersbeschränkungen
wenn dann um eure reaktionen darauf
bezeichnen sind auch das irgendwie die
einnahmen dadurch irgendwie entfernt
wurden nicht weiter ich kann das
vielleicht ein bisschen nachvollziehen
mit ab 18 freigegeben
einnahmen wegnehmen was man eigentlich
dass der gezeigt habe die rechte aller
leute ist auch alles scheißegal ich
wollte euch in italien oder darüber
informieren dass google leitete wieder
auf 38 da gemacht hat youtube wenn ihr
bescheid könnte man vielleicht mal
wieder ein video machen dass wir
vielleicht ein bisschen was wir alles
machen
die heutigen video ich will gar nicht
lange durch gefeiert und videos findet
irgendwo irgendwas eingeblendet und ja
tut mir leid mit dem wirt 8
[Musik]